[Music]  so crying in the club I collaborated  with SIA which was really cool  Charli XCX I did a couple songs with her  Pharrell I did a song with him um Ryan  Tedder okay your lip literally naming  like the hottest like songwriters  performers like thanks I mean I got  really lucky it was amazing it was  amazing I mean Pharrell I met him once  and I was just like oh I know me too I  was like yeah crazy that's pretty much  me the night sound effect he's the  nicest person though yeah so nice and  he's so humble and he makes you feel I  feel like he you know he's so incredible  and for every artist and producer and  anybody um you know he is the cream of  the crop like he's just amazing and I  feel like he probably knows that he has  that effect on people so he makes an  effort to make you feel welcome and at  home which i think is yeah is really  nice  [Music]  you